Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the American post-apocalyptic
thriller film called “Vanishing on 7th street.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in a theater where a crowd
of people is enjoying a film.
The projectionist Paul is in the other room
controlling the projections.
He has a headlamp on to help him see through
the dark cinema hall.
Paul is a massive bookworm and loves to read
while he is at work.
We see him read a book called the lost colony
of Roanoke in which the people of a town disappear
mysteriously.
When he gets up to push some buttons in the
control panel, the lights go off leaving the
theater in complete darkness.
Thankfully, Paul has his headlamp which he
uses to walk inside the theater room.
But to his surprise, the place that was filled
with people some seconds ago is now completely
empty.
He walks out to the hallways and the lights
suddenly turn on.
To Paul’s utter surprise, the hallway is
filled with people’s clothes and popcorn
boxes on the floor as if all of them disappeared
at once.
He runs down the hallway calling for his colleagues.
A guard with a torchlight who is just as confused
hears him.
The two then walk around the place looking
for people.
The guard notices someone in a dark corner
and approaches them, but his torchlight stops
working midway.
When Paul looks back at him, the guard is
gone and his clothes are on the floor.
Somewhere else in a hospital, a nurse named
Rosemary is distraught because of a similar
event.
The place is dark and no one is around except
for her.
She walks down the hallway with a torchlight,
but finds no one.
Rosemary enters the operation room and finds
a patient on the bed.
His body has been cut as if the surgeons left
him mid-surgery.
All of a sudden, the lights of the room go
out and the patient disappears.
A terrified Rosemary starts looking for her
baby Manny.
The next morning, a TV reporter named Luke
Ryder wakes up to see his partner hasn’t
returned home.
He blows the candles on his side table which
is probably the reason he hasn’t vanished
like the rest.
Luke also notices his phone is out of battery
and the power is out.
Ignoring everything, he dresses up and goes
outside only to see the streets filled with
abandoned cars and clothes.
Confused, he starts looking around and witnesses
a plane crash nearby.
Not knowing what to do, he rushes to his work
and sees the situation is similar.
All this time, he doesn’t notice a subtle
shadow following him.
Luke discovers the power is out even at his
office and none of the phones work.
He then looks at a picture of him and his
girlfriend when suddenly a shadow outside
the room catches his attention.
After Luke leaves, we see darkness taking
over the picture.
Seventy-Two hours after the first disappearance,
Luke is in the street trying to start a car.
Suddenly, a man bangs on the window, asking
for help.
He has a lighter in his hands that has stopped
working.
Luke locks the doors and lets the shadow take
over the man.
The poor guy disappears within seconds leaving
only his clothes behind.
After watching the man die, Luke continues
looking for a car that works.
A little girl with a torchlight watches him
from nearby but he doesn’t notice her.
In his search, Luke finds a car with its headlights
on but it doesn’t start.
Finally, in the next block, he comes across
a well-lit pub.
He quickly goes inside but sees no one around.
The bar also has people’s clothes lying
on the floor.
He then pours himself some alcohol to calm
down.
Looking for the source of power, he reaches
the basement.
It has a backup generator that lights up the
whole place but to his disappointment, it
is about to run out of fuel.
All of a sudden, a twelve-year-old kid named
James points a rifle at him.
He asks Luke to put his torch down and takes
him upstairs.
James is afraid because Luke is a stranger
but Luke assures the kid that he will not
harm him.
James finally puts the gun down and introduces
himself.
He turns out to be the son of the owner of
the pub.
He and his mother were the only ones left
after the very first disappearance.
His mother has gone to a church nearby to
ask for help and James is waiting for her.
Luke decides to be honest with the kid and
says that it is still dark outside at 11 am.
Since the first disappearance, the sun has
been rising late and setting early.
In a few days, they won’t have sunlight,
so the chances of James’s mother returning
are very low.
James doesn’t believe him and insists that
he will wait until she arrives.
Luke tries to convince James to come with
him if he wants to survive.
However, James stays adamant in his decision.
A while later, the nurse Rosemary barges into
the pub frantically searching for her child,
Manny.
She blames the other two for abducting Manny
and demands them to give him back.
The lady then goes crazy and points a gun
at the two.
She only calms down after firing a shot at
the counter.
Somewhere nearby, the projectionist Paul wanders
through the dark street.
He is seconds away from being engulfed in
the darkness when he reaches a well-lit bus
stop and is saved.
However, he is heavily injured and cannot
move anymore.
Back at the pub, James calms Rosemary and
offers her some water.
The woman says that she is looking for her
nine months old son Manny.
The movie goes into a flashback and we see
Rosemary in the hospital, taking a smoke break.
Suddenly, the lights go out and the noise
of a car crash follows.
She is saved because of the lighter she had
in hand.
She somehow survives the night and goes to
her house the next morning.
There, she goes up to the crib in her room,
hoping to see her baby only to find him missing.
Back in the present, Rosemary brings out glow
sticks from her bag that she has been using
to survive.
As they talk, a loud scream from outside catches
their attention.
They contemplate if they should go look if
there’s a survivor.
Luke doesn’t want to take the risk but the
other two insist he save the person.
At last, Luke goes searching and finds an
injured Paul at the bus stop.
They hear whispers from the shadow that moves
closer.
Luke somehow drags Paul to the pub, putting
his life at risk.
Rosemary helps Paul and dresses his wound.
A while later, he gains consciousness and
starts explaining how he got there.
According to Paul, after everything went down,
he was safe because of his headlamp.
But for a few minutes, it stopped working
and he was hit by someone on his head.
The shadows soon took over him and brought
him to the void.
They whispered in Paul’s ears, making him
beg for help.
However, right then, his headlamp started
to work again and he was back in the streets.
Paul somehow managed to get to the bus stop
and that is where Luke found him.
When asked about the person who hit him, Paul
tells them that there was no body or face;
it was just a shadow.
Rosemary, who is a catholic, tells them that
they are left behind as a punishment by God.
Luke counters that there is no god and they
do not deserve this “punishment”.
Suddenly, the lights flicker again, and they
go down to the basement to check the backup
generator.
As Luke fixes the generator, Paul tells them
about the book he read earlier; the lost colony
of Roanoke.
He explains that in 1587, people from an island
colony named Roanoke mysteriously disappeared
overnight.
The rest of the world only found out when
a boat with supplies came by and the workers
found the island empty.
The people had left all their food, livestock,
and clothing as it is.
The only thing they left behind was the word
Croatoan written on a metal fence.
Luke inquires what the word means but Paul
claims it to be a mystery.
Frustrated, Paul starts kicking the generator
and injures himself.
He is then brought and kept on the pool table
by the others.
Rosemary asks Luke to get some ice for the
injured.
While getting those, Luke remembers the last
time he was at his office.
He is in the broadcasting studio where he
finds the last news recording.
The woman reporter vanishes into thin air
while talking.
Then, a live feed from Chicago broadcasts
is played.
A person warns everyone to keep a light with
them all the time.
He also claims that the darkness may take
on any shape or form to lure you to your death,
hence not to trust anybody except light.
Back in the present, Luke gets an idea to
get out of the situation.
If he somehow finds a way to get to Chicago,
they can meet the other survivors and then
decide what to do.
He remembers the working truck he has encountered
earlier and suggests to others that they should
retrieve the vehicle.
Since the generator can fail at any time,
they should instead use it to ignite the vehicle
and drive away from the place.
Rosemary is skeptical of the idea because
she believes all this is happening for a reason.
But Luke persuades her to join the plan.
They decide that James should stay with Paul
and take care of him while Rosemary and Luke
go to get the vehicle.
In the following scene, Rosemary and Luke
manage to get to the truck and start pushing
it to get it back to the pub.
At the same time, Paul starts questioning
James about several things in his life.
He is slowly losing consciousness but James
asks him to stay awake.
He requests James to play a song that they
both enjoy.
James starts imagining the bar full of people
and enjoys the fantasy amidst the chaos.
He is only brought back when Paul asks him
to get him some water.
James goes to the sink to fetch it but suddenly
the lights flicker and go off.
Somewhere else, Luke and Rosemary take a break
from pushing the vehicle.
Luke tells her about his ex-wife, Anna, in
Chicago.
As they talk, they see a little girl holding
a torchlight at a distance.
It is the same girl who was watching Luke
earlier when he was on the road.
They try to get closer to her but the little
girl runs away.
Luke goes behind her and is almost engulfed
by the shadows but he is saved at the last
minute because of the truck’s headlight.
In the following scene, Paul gets up and looks
for James only to find his clothes on the
floor.
He walks up to the basement and sees a door
that leads to a well-lit tunnel.
He goes inside, still looking for James but
comes across a dead end.
The lights start to go out on their own and
he is soon engulfed by the shadows.
But then, it is shown that Paul’s clothes
are on the pool table.
Him getting to the tunnel was just his dream.
Paul was actually unconscious and was taken
by the shadows while he was still on the pool
table.
James quickly comes back to Paul and sees
that he is gone.
In the meantime, Luke and Rosemary’s torch
lights start running out of batteries all
at once.
Luke tries to ignite the fuel to create light
but they’ve got no lighter.
So the two go to a nearby hospital, searching
for any source of light.
There, Luke ignites a fire with a matchstick
and a cloth.
Rosemary goes to find rubbing alcohol which
they can use as fuel.
But on her way, she hears a baby crying and
sees a stroller right under a streetlight.
Unknown that it is the shadow’s tactic to
lure her in, Rosemary walks up to the stroller.
She notices the stroller is empty but it is
too later as she is taken by the shadows.
Luke, who is now alone, somehow gets back
to the pub with the truck.
He reunites with James and the two get in
the truck ready to leave for Chicago.
Luke uses the backup generator to start the
engine and the two finally drive away.
However, they are soon met with an accident
that happens to be right in front of a church.
James insists he has to go in to look for
his mother.
Despite Luke warning him to stay in the car,
James runs inside the church.
Just then, Luke sees the word Croatoan carved
in a road sign.
He rushes back to James and saves him seconds
before the shadows get him.
Luke then asks the kid to return with him
but is ignored again.
James claims that his mother is nearby because
he heard her call him, unknown that it was
just a trap set by the shadows.
Suddenly, the car’s headlights turn off
and Luke vanishes in thin air.
Now, the only survivor left is James.
He sits in between the lit candles of the
church but all of them slowly extinguish.
The next morning, the sun finally rises.
Surprisingly, James has survived the night
and is sleeping where he was yesterday.
The little girl from earlier approaches him
and introduces herself as Briana.
She shows James her solar flashlight that
she has been using to survive.
Later, both of them come outside the church
and see a horse in the middle of the road.
The two get on the horse and start their journey,
presumably to a safe place.
Soon, the sun sets and we see the shadows
of Luke, Rosemary, and Paul watching over
the kids.
The movie ends as Briana and James continue
their journey.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.